without commenting on anybody's motives
today historically opposition
immigration United States has been
racially and religiously motivated in
the ugliest nastiest way possible hi I'm
Matt Welch for recent TV I'm at Freedom
Fest in Las Vegas with one of the single
most influential private citizens in
Washington DC Grover Norquist Grover
thank you very much for joining us we're
in the middle of talking about
immigration reform in this country you
have been pushing very hard for
immigration reform for about 30 years
there's a lot of sort of Republican
conservative grassroots opposition to
those that we see in the House of
Representatives don't the opposition
have a point about kind of the largeness
and unwieldy myth of the bill what
you're trying to reform is a big messy
collection of previous pieces of
legislation so if you're going to
address all the stupid things we've been
doing you're gonna it's gonna be a long
bill we could do it piecemeal except
there's a lot of opposition by the labor
unions the left the reason why we're in
the mess trend is that organized labor
didn't like the guest worker program we
had under Eisenhower
so they killed it the reason we're in
the mess we're in is that they put in
regulations in the 20s which was
discriminatory and deliberately meant to
be and we're trying to extricate
ourselves from that history and come up
with a reasonable level of immigration
we have a 55 mile an hour speed limit
immigration policy when the cars and the
roads are built for 75 and 80 and we
didn't when we had the 55 mile an hour
speed limit under Carter run around
saying we must enforce the law first and
before we consider changing the 55
miners be them it we must imprison
everybody who was involved in the
illegal speeding
that's silly you say it changed the
stupid law and then you enforce it we
need to reform immigration so we have
dramatically higher levels of
immigration both of high-skilled
of low-skilled people that's what built
the country so it makes us different
than the rest of the world it's why
we're the future and China isn't is how
well we do immigration and we've been
doing it with one hand tied behind our
back with stupid laws let's move in the
direction of having the laws catch up
with our reality which is we've been
very welcoming to 11 million people we
put up a big sign that said jobs
available Help Wanted and there was
another little sign over saying don't
cross this line and they decided to
react to reality which was the draw of
jobs and opportunity rather than the
little official sign that said don't
don't do what we're asking to do you
hear a lot of discussion from Republican
opponents of comprehensive reform and
also from gleeful Democrats that this
issue threatens to sort of rip apart the
Republican GOP conservative coalition is
that true and we sort of / why has this
become such an emotional question
particularly for opponents it's very
interesting first of all this is a
problem for the Democratic Party it's
the Democrats that spent the first two
years of Obama's administration not
doing anything why because they're
paralyzed by organized labor by their
radical environmentalists who don't like
people at all and the Union people who
don't want more people coming in and
working so Obama who killed the 2007
bill by coming in with the amendment to
do in a guest worker program then
becomes president says he's for all this
stuff doesn't lift a finger for the two
years when he could have done it any day
of the week so he now has to come and
pretend to be for it I worry that he has
every intention of killing it hoping
that Republicans who get the blame
within the center-right you have some
people like john o'sullivan foreigner
came to our country to write for
National Review doesn't understand
America he's still British he thinks
that we're just Britain moved West he'd
understand we're a country that decided
not to be British affirmative that we're
not
we're out of here and he gave his speech
20 years ago saying immigrants come here
they go on welfare they become Democrats
as battle and I went up to him
afterwards and said you gave an
interesting speech on the evils of
welfare why would you drag the
immigrants into it most of the people
whose lives are damaged by welfare and
dependency for welfare we're born here
I mean tip of the iceberg is the
immigrants who showed up not but most of
the people are Americans who welfare
hurts why don't you talk about welfare
you thought you're talking about
immigration
he said well of course that is the
problem but we can't reform welfare and
we can keep the immigrants out well
actually you haven't been able to keep
the immigrants out and we can't reform
welfare even under Clinton as president
including a much ignored provision
blocking much of welfare to illegal
immigrants at the time there are a lot
of people who are mad about welfare but
they scream at immigrants they're mad
about the entitlement programs like the
Heritage Foundation which says do you
know that immigrants come in would get 3
times as much out of Medicare as they
put in a faucet sure about babies born
in the United States we have a flawed
entitlement program why would you pick
out immigrants as opposed to everybody
else and then they say our education
system doesn't work and people don't
learn to write English in American
history very well yeah I went through it
it sucks for people who are born here so
there's this weird transference of
frustration we can't reform education
but we could keep them out of it we
can't reform entitlements but we could
keep them out of it so instead of fixing
the flaws the United States we're trying
to call names for immigrants the problem
is it distracts you from the real
problem our entitlement programs our
welfare system are unionized and
bureaucratized education system
and redirects people's animus at
completely innocent parties who are
trying to become Americans and didn't
sign up for any of this stuff we did it
we can we created this mess that we live
in without commenting on anybody's
motives
today historically opposition
immigration United States has been
racially and religiously motivated in
the ugliest nastiest way possible the
Chinese Exclusion Act first I had the
one that says no Chinese prostitutes and
criminals then two years later they said
okay we mean no Chinese people but the
first one was just snotty as if what you
were keeping out were criminals and
prostitutes and then they passed the
real law they wanted which was no
Chinese people which we didn't really
fix until like 1943 the anti Irish stuff
the anti Eastern European Jewish stuff
from the twenty one and twenty four loss
these things were designed to keep them
out we were told that Jews had very low
IQs because somebody tested them during
World War one and that the Irish would
never simulate because they couldn't
learn English you know all of this stuff
very very ugly the critics of
immigration need to spend more time
disassociating themselves from the
history of that movement if they want to
be heard on whatever merits they think
they have by the targets of their
apparent animus and to pretend that
there's no requirement to deal with that
history i think is silly related to that
you hear a lot of talk from the kind of
john mccain lindsey graham's of the
world and some other commenters that
basically the republicans have to do
this electoral ii forget about it
whether it's a good idea or a bad idea
that they're committing suicide if they
don't sign on to something do you agree
with that and do you think that's an
effective persuasive argument well not
race about in argument for people who
don't see themselves as political people
you have to do this because other people
will vote against you
I mean that's an argument for lots of
dumb things the challenge is and I think
they do it backwards then then the acted
opponents of immigration say well you
say if we pass immigration reform all
the expenditures above with us we say
that's not true let's just ramen nobody
says that if we don't deal with the ten
million eleven million undocumented and
stop threatening to deport them you
cannot have a civil conversation with
Asian Americans and Hispanic Americans
and subcontinent Americans because all
of them ones who vote and her citizens
have a relative a friend a neighbor
who's threatened with deportation and
this idea that I've heard from some
conservatives well we're gonna go up and
say ma'am you know we want to talk to
you where the Republicans we're pro-life
and you're pro-life and we're for
traditional marriage and we're for low
taxes and why don't we talk about all
things that we agree on while egor here
goes upstairs and grabs your aunt and
drags her down the stairs and manacles
and throws are in the back of the
vehicle here and takes her across the
border to Guatemala and then we can have
our conversation about things we agree
on you never have that conversation so
it's not that if you do immigration
reform you win the votes of
asian-americans Hispanic Americans and
all immigrant communities talk to
Catholic Americans a lot of them have a
collective memory that's a hundred years
old for crying out loud but they
wherever it's you know our
great-great-grandmother were immigrants
and they were mistreated and when they
see it happening again they personalize
it they mean me they say they mean them
but they mean me so the votes that
Republicans are losing are not just
Hispanics
it's way broader than that throw away
comprehensive immigration reform
you can vote yes yea or nay on a single
idea you verify would you vote yay or
nay absent immigration I'm not in favor
of you verify putting the government
between every American and a job
I'd much rather I think the way to have
secure borders as a guest worker program
I think that the height of fences is not
what does it we went from a million
people being arrested a year down to
40,000 with Eisenhower's bracero program
and then when the Democrats and the
labor unions killed it went back up to a
million so you want to have the secure
border have doors that people will go to
because they can come in and work that's
the important thing people that think
that building higher walls or deeper
walls or moats and alligators and stuff
and then a police state when you get
here in case we didn't catch you the
last time they're chasing after a
problem it can be fixed
more easily by expanding Liberty rather
than contracting it on that note thank
you very much Grover for the update on
immigration reform
for recent TV I'm out well